thomas villanueva is so pleased with the
day's harvest that he breaks into sung
as he delivers a sample for the kitchen
[Music]
his wife liliana aranda will use it to
prepare lunch after working outdoors
everyone is hungry
thank the water for watering the plants
the compost for feeding them
that compost was made from human
excrement all perfectly normal for
farmer thomas villanueva and his family
even at the dinner table it's no taboo
given their salad and vegetables were
grown with nutrients from human feces
on the edge of the small mexican town of
tepatixla in the state of mexico the
orlan tiali farm grows fruit and
vegetables
everything here is fertilized
exclusively with homemade human dung
[Music]
we're completing the cycle
what comes from the earth is digested
and excreted
they eat their own vegetables but they
also sell them at markets
all plants need nutrients to grow
especially nitrogen and phosphorus
olintiali is a fully organic farm and
artificial fertilizers are banned
thomas villanueva says they're expensive
and bad for the soil so he and his team
invest a lot of time and effort
collecting excrement from dry toilets
mixing it with natural ingredients like
stone powder or straw
to transform it into a rich compost over
a number of months
the activity of bacteria leads to high
temperatures during composting that heat
kills any
pathogens this compost here is now ready
and it's most pleasant like fertile soil
they use it to grow various types of
cabbage beet root broccoli fruit and a
whole lot more
we've come to the small town of okotepec
in the state of morelos
here architect cesar anjorva has also
looked at ways of recycling feces
he decided to try out something
completely new
[Music]
this is an ecological neighborhood that
i set up more than 20 years ago
i wanted to show that homes can use dry
toilets and not pollute any water
in other words toilets that divert the
urine away from the feces and that are
not flushed with water
these toilets are not connected to the
sewage system either
urine lands in the front here
poop at the back just add a bit of soil
and that's it
[Music]
a lot of raw sewage in mexico flows
directly into lakes rivers and the sea
something cesar anjoreve finds
outrageous
he believes dry toilets are the solution
and gives workshops teaching people how
to build and use them but getting people
to actually talk about poop is the
biggest challenge
it's like they're afraid of it
but his sanitation system forces people
to think about the subject rather than
just flushing it away
[Music]
as an architect i discovered that in my
profession water is seen as a means of
transporting away feces in urine
i found that terrible
so my work aims to change this
perception of water
[Applause]
what i'm doing is reviving the knowledge
and understanding of water that our
ancestors had they didn't see excrement
as something dirty but is something that
needs to be returned to the earth
those ancestors used human feces and
other organic waste to develop fertile
islands known as chanampas used for
growing crops in wetland areas
they've been used in mexico since
ancient times on one chinampa on the
edge of mexico city lucio usobiaga wants
to keep that heritage alive
[Music]
the chinampas are one rare example of
how we humans have helped to promote
life and biodiversity so they're a very
powerful example of how we can live in
harmony with nature
he runs a regenerative farming project
called arcatiera
the idea is to grow organic produce
working as closely as possible with
nature the produce is then sold to
restaurants in mexico city
dry toilets are a must here there's
neither electricity nor running water
and the tunampas are protected areas so
waste needs to be dealt with
lucio usubiaga sees the excrement that
has been collected here as a resource
we need to give back to the earth what
we've received in the shape of food
otherwise you get an imbalance leading
to pests and depleted soil
to feed the plants properly you need to
return all that's left over back to the
soil
right now they're only fertilizing fruit
trees with human dung they want to first
make sure they can reliably filter out
any pathogens residual hormones and
medication in the compost before they
start using it for vegetables too
back to the olin tiali organic farm
thomas via nueva's customers know how
his vegetables are grown and they
wholeheartedly approve
[Music]
has a bad image in our society but we
know that this composting process makes
it perfectly hygienic
[Music]
a cycle of giving and taking eating and
excreting something that triggers
revulsion elsewhere is seen here as the
most natural thing in the world
[Music]
you